so for years we've been filming footage
on green screens and there's always been
one simple trick if we know we're
supposed to replace the background with
an outdoor environment it's called going
outside because nothing can match the
natural energy and brightness of the sun
however today that might change because
recently we've upgraded our studio with
a giant green screen and huge powerful
led lights some of the brightest you can
possibly get what i'm wondering is can
we harness the power of the sun
inside our studio in order to prove that
this is possible we're going to have to
light a subject as brightly as they
would be underneath direct sunlight and
i think we have a perfect candidate for
this a perfect test subject our newest
intern who happens to have a flight suit
he might need it because honestly lights
of this brightness have been known to
burn people so we're gonna have to do
this pretty cautiously i'm hoping he can
withstand the blast
this has been a long time coming we got
a lot of lights in the studio now we
have a lot of really cool lights we have
very tiny ones we have really really
bright ones and like overall we kind of
have to figure out what we have we got
to reorganize a little bit and see what
our lighting inventory is most of the
lights we're using now at this point are
aperture lights and they're really cool
is this a sponsored video no not a
sponsored video but that's just the
reality of it they have been a great
partner to work with and they make some
very bright led lights
thankfully today we've brought an actual
light meter so we can measure this stuff
what do we got here how bright is this
one
this is i can't even see it it's too
bright so this is
six and a half thousand lux so the unit
i'm getting here on the light meter is a
lux
and basically what is a lux well a lux
is a measurement of light on a
particular spot and specifically with a
light meter it's easy you can see this
is the spot we're getting our reading
from now the lumen that's overall light
output basically turn on a light bulb
how much light can the light bulb emit
and it's not about like oh what's the
couch how bright is your couch versus
how bright is your seat i'm like no
that's that's lux but a lumen is
the whole space for reference if you
were to look at the sun the amount of
lux that's going to hit your eyeball is
like 100 000. so obviously like the
amount of total lumens the sun's
outputting it's probably astronomical i
don't know the exact reading of that but
what we're talking about here is how
much light can we get on a single source
and the sun we got a hundred thousand
so to reach the sun we're gonna need a
lot more output than any single light is
capable of luckily aperture has sent us
a bunch of new lights and they are super
bright so i think mark's gonna get
screwed here i mean the amount of
photons being emitted at his skin might
change his dna leave the mutations you
think mark will get in the comments
below anyways we might be able to
surpass the brightness of the sun within
the walls of our studio if we can get
mark's face above 100 000 lux that's
like the same as him like going in a
spaceship how close to the sun can we
get mark
oh my god are you in space
yeah man
not yet but i will be hey what's up it's
mark flyman
man
[Music]
there is one thing we're going to run
into today and it's called the inverse
square
wall and this determines how bright
something is in relationship to uh its
distance from that light so for instance
this light is illuminating me right now
but if i were to double the distance
between myself and this light
i'm not getting half as bright i'm being
reduced to uh 25
as bright because that's just how
photons begin to fall off as you get
away from that light how does it play
into here well we have a lot of lights
we have a lot of light stands and we're
only going to be able to physically get
those lights close together you know
based on the size of the space the size
of the stands so we're going to try and
find that sweet spot
where mark is nice and close to the
lights but there's still enough physical
space for him to even be there so how
far away is it gonna have to be
and how is that going to affect our
readings i'm kind of worried about them
blowing a few like a breaker or whatever
so i'm gonna be safe my fingers will be
on control s i mean i'm not feeling
great about our power situation mainly
because of what we're turning on and how
many we're turning on but
you know we ran it from a couple
different areas in the room and uh
that's the best we could hope for right
now everything else is gonna be great
let me kill the house lights
all right now we are at pure low
illumination the only light in here is
what's leaking through
the skylights that we've covered
and that is giving us about
one lux this is how bright it is in the
middle of the night with a full moon but
i can't see a damn thing i got
sunglasses oh okay good so mark we're
going to chart his course through the
solar system as he gets closer to the
sun in order to do that i want to work
our way up to this we're going to start
with the smallest lights and then go to
our largest lights that way each time we
flip them on we get to see that nice
jump in our light readings so to start
we're going to start with these little
aperture
god striking jesus this is our smallest
light and this is one of the aperture
mcs they're battery powered i don't know
how long they're gonna last but we got a
bunch of them so you are three meters
away from this light and where are we at
ren we are at seven lux
seven that's it oh seven or eight well
good thing we got
seven more of these
wren where are we at in the solar system
we are we're still further out than
pluto right now we're further out than
pluto you're out in the oort cloud
that's pretty cold honestly but it's
nice
calmness of space the endless ocean
amidst the stars all right we got we're
we're we're six lights deep
45 lux right now 45. four to five last
but not least our last of the mcs this
is number eight
78 so we're 78 looks so we're at pluto
dude we're past pluto we shot by pluto
oh wow dude we didn't even stop at the
gift shop flying past pluto i just
wanted to say neil degrasse tyke sin can
suck it
pluto is a planet and i will take no
other questions mark has now finally
entered our solar system and he's even
passed pluto at this point that's still
very far away from earth though all
right because once again earth is a
hundred thousand so we're still under a
thousandth of the light that we receive
here on earth so let's upgrade it
hey everybody welcome to my safe space
i'm taking a break from editing this
video to tell you about today's sponsor
betterhelp because betterhelp can help
you escape the void
of space or of your mind
betterhelp is an online therapy platform
that makes it super easy to get
connected with a therapist i found it
super daunting to get into therapy and i
hesitated for a long time because you
have to go through insurance you have to
do all these different things better
help all of those barriers of entry are
completely removed you go online you
fill out a questionnaire and within 48
hours you can get linked with somebody
who can help improve your mental health
so i got connected with my therapist
tanner and over the course of our
sessions i was able to really work on my
anxiety and we worked on concrete tools
to recontextualize it and those are
tools i would have never had if i didn't
go through therapy your entire therapy
experience can be just through your
phone you can do voice therapy sessions
video therapy sessions and you also get
unlimited messages to talk at any time
of the day there's a broad range of
expertise in better help's 20 000 plus
therapist network that gives you access
to help that may not be available in
your area you can request a new
therapist at no additional charge any
time
so if you guys have been avoiding
therapy
i think it's time to go check out
betterhelp join the three million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health by going to betterhelp.com
corridor crew for 10 off your first
month of therapy it helped me
tremendously and i think it can help you
too if you're struggling and with that
we're gonna head back to mark getting
every light in the studio blasting his
face
we got these small panels they're amaran
uh 60s they're pretty bright but we have
a lot of them so i think let's start
turning these on and seeing what kind of
readings we're going to get
are we already in the hundreds
730 yeah we are oh that was an order of
magnitude we just went from 77 lux to
about 700. 726 lux
we cleared way past neptune and uranus
whoa just with this one light we just
okay so the speed of that's pro really
fast you hit like the afterburners
these planets whatever they're blue
gashes who cares all right let's hit the
next ammo around
yep it did it
oh wow we're at 1400 lux right now
what the heck did i miss saturn we
totally sailed past saturn man i thought
you knew how to fly this ship i don't
know how to fly i'm kind of like just
careening off from sheer momentum i
don't think i have any control over this
but we still have a ways to go before we
get to jupiter
that's where they go to go more stupider
i gotta say this this right here feels
like normal illumination for say a video
right actually yeah it's around this
much illumination that's usually used in
like studio lighting environments we
have another light that's slightly
brighter the aputure 120ds
i'm hoping this can give us a nice boost
and we see a little jump from it that
felt like we got a nice boost i saw the
brightness levels go up
we are getting close to jupiter we're at
28.74
lux jupiter's 3700. it's so funny
because the original small lights seem
like they're losing battery power just
by comparison to every new light added
they're behind us this was before we
even entered the solar system they're so
they're in our rear view mirror we have
a special contraption here it's like
it's a little devious all right
so we're about to add five more in one
go wait a minute that means we're gonna
soar past jupiter we keep missing our
planets guys our home is earth that's
our that's that should be our
destination so the first 120 gave a
boost around 6 700. let's see what a
second one does
this one's on
3100 hold that anticipation one more
light might get us exactly at jupiter
one more
thirty six thirty we're just shy of
jupiter come on jupiter
i can see it
go
oh we shot past jupiter
this array of lights you just added
brought us up to 4 500 lux
i'm starting to feel a little bit of
warmth you know what i mean just on my
skin i'm noticing just like the tiniest
bit it's just because i've been sitting
in front of it like just like just a
little bit on my cheeks like feels a
little warm like a early morning
sunshine rising up over the horizon
we're starting to actually enter the
territory of our our really big lights
we got some single source aperture 300ds
and they have fresnel lenses on it now
adding these fresnels is going to
significantly increase our light
intensity because
every light that we have set up right
now is either a panel or a light that
doesn't have a lens on it meaning the
light is going to shoot out in every
direction from its light source but the
fresnel lenses allow us to actually
focus in the light on a certain spot i
have high hopes for these ones so let's
go uh 200
oh
oh my gosh
that's right oh
8 000
that's what i'm talking about we just
jumped 3 000 lux in one light go and we
have how many more of those three or two
we got two more of those yeah we still
got a ways to go to get into mars
jupiter's 3 700 lux mars is 43 000 lux
and we're sitting at 8 000 right now
well then let's kick this baby into
overdrive here's another one oh aaron
no that's full zoom all the way out
extended
10 000 lux
one more we got one more let's do one
more
why not
here we go we got one more three hundred
a hundred
twelve and a half thousand luxe
i'm feeling good the heat is building up
i noticed the difference on my left side
of my face where those three bigger
lights are than my right side like
there's actually some heat starting to
build up on my cheekbones we're actually
starting to reach our like the biggest
flex we have okay i'm hoping for some
spikes if can we get to earth with these
all right here we go
boom
it's not really helping that didn't
really do anything maybe it's because
it's so dispersed
we're yeah we're at 14 000
damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's
super cool we got one more 600 here
after this we only have one final option
final nova 600 is going up
and it's bright
that's about 20 000.
we have we have one final light here
this is the aputure
600
and it happens to have their best
fresnel lens on it
this one i have i've burned my skin
permission to put my helmet on mark yes
it's definitely time for the helmet
putting it on captain
three two one
we're at twenty two thousand twenty four
thousand twenty eight thirty
hit 40k briefly there we're we're
officially at the brightness of mars we
were at 40 000. all right we got to mars
that's an achievement this is high noon
on mars
nice this light
has made all other lights look dim
we have some garbage lights over here
let's just put
they're not garbage lights deep dude we
need every light every able bodied light
in the studio
yeah do you have a dean i need your
phone light bring it down
we're kind of we're reaching our end of
this end stages here where we're going
to want to do the hyperdrive here right
now he's roughly at
three meters from
the lights so we're going to increase in
increments of about a foot we're going
to move up one foot at a time and see
the massive jumps that these lights are
going to give us is going to increase
the heat let us know if you begin to get
uncomfortable this is an actual jumpsuit
it's flame retardant so it's okay
let's hit warp drive all right
initiating warp one
all right
that's it but just you wait
42 000. all right let's go in another
foot then initiative warp two
warp two
warp two
[Music]
forty five thousand all right it's like
we're getting closer to these ones but
not the other ones
all right let's move on to another foot
warp three more dirt
all right wren let's see what warp
three's giving us
55 000 luts
my chest is really starting to build
i can definitely feel the radiant heat
hitting me here my suit is starting to
feel warm to the touch
four four three two one
oh my god what dude just by lowering it
83 000 lux
see we're making progress finally i'm
hoping that warp five is gonna begin to
do it we're not one meteor yet or five
here we go
111
000 lux
sam we passed earth
yeah we passed earth i was paying
attention we're finally past earth thank
god
we have two more destinations before the
sun we have venus and we have mercury
it's beautiful i don't know what normal
brightness is i have to remind myself
i'm looking through two visors
more
more
more
what are you doing i'm putting a light
in but this is
okay
i think with this 300 we can hit venus
it's pointed right it is freaking i know
well the incinerator the incinerator is
about to begin let's let's demo this
first one here we go three two one
right now
our our aperture 300 is putting them
roughly at venus okay
yeah it's literally venus
are you using your phone to underexpose
and read the marker yeah i can't see it
otherwise
the incinerator is about to begin
here all right aim it down adam let's
bring it up
go ahead and bring him in
how you feeling buddy i'm good i can
take it oh it's like hot to the touch
dude you could feel the visor
yeah
he skipped off of venus and it's now
heading towards mercury but if he gets
any closer he will burn
mark
would you stand up from your chair
and interface in as close to that light
as we can get it
what are we at
we're at 260 260
280 300
three forty
three forty
i can see the light go towards the light
mark go towards the light get more light
what are we at
okay
the light the lights just
we're breaking the breakers we can't
bring them any closer okay
like
we've just broken like two or three
breakers here
like that we we flew too close there's
no way we can continue this experiment
after that
what was our final reading
i i want to know what this number is
424
000 lux
push him any closer to the lights he
will incinerate if we go any brighter
than this we will literally melt him
like everything he's wearing here will
start to
liquefy like we can't go brighter than
this
i notice
it's getting so hot it's i hear little
crackles as the plastic starts to change
shape
wow there you go buddy
that's no joke
feeling good
feeling like you just traveled through
the solar system and i got to see this
with my own eyes oh my god
that's bright
this right now
if people can't tell is unbelievably
bright to the point where if i was
looking at it with my own eyes the sun
does not compare to that i'm like
squinting through the sunglasses the
heat that i feel on my face i wish we
had a thermometer like a laser
thermometer just to see what kind of
sheer
volume of light is hitting my eyes this
is brighter than the sun on earth at
least so
i'm at
one over 240 i'm at f15 i'm at 500 iso
that's like
extreme outdoor settings you know what
i'm saying like you'd be stopping down
using your shutter
that's what we'd be getting
i mean if we're in really bright outside
light yeah let's go outside let's go
outside yeah
i'm not going to touch the camera
settings here i want to see if he's
significantly dimmer or brighter well
let's take a look this is what he looks
like under direct sunlight oh my god i'm
looking at the exposure here and it
looks the same it looks exactly the same
what we were getting with him sitting
there at that distance in that chair was
pretty identical to what we're capturing
right now i would say
inside he's like just a hair brighter
actually we kicked the sun's ass yeah we
did that's sitting in a chair a few feet
away from these lights that's definitely
brighter than the sunlight we're getting
yeah are you all right are you sweating
yeah
i could take the sun in a fist fight and
i will do it any day i'm calling you out
son you mean me i'll come to your town
you come to my town i'll
fight you any day or night we're doing
this on my terms we're going to do this
inside
if you're not much of a or youtuber
come in my house and fight me so yeah if
you guys enjoyed seeing us turn on all
the lights in the studio subscribe
because next
we're going to turn off all the lights
in the studio